direction auxerre à présent on a entendu
tout à l'heure l'ump guillaume larrivé
gif erez le maire sortant socialiste est
en duplex également d'auxerre ce soir
nous allons retrouver tout de suite et
gif et reiz avec un score peut être plus
serré que l'on ce que vous pouviez
imaginer pour ce premier tour
oui bien sûr d'abord je constate que les
auxerrois m'ont placé en tête et puis je
suis regroupent dans la marge d'erreur
comparé aux sondages qui avançaient 45%
des voix ce que en termes d des mandats
les îles je constate ce soir que le
front de gauche tokia pas le le score
qui était prévu en tout cas qu'il
escomptait du bab le front national
également de la tablette pas la barre
des 10 et donc c'est une situation
inédite comparés aux informations qui
étaient les lots très bien ce sera un
duel entre le candidat de l'ump et moi
même et vous étiez plutôt confiant avant
ce premier tour en 2008 vous aviez été
réélu dès le premier tour c'est comment
vous le prenez comment vous l'analysez
vous alors ce score de ce soir on va
jouer une analyse de manière assez
simple j'ai conduit une campagne qui
avait bien mis au coeur de mon
engagement est au coeur de ma campagne
tout simplement une élection aux
municipales une élection locale quand je
regarde un certain nombre de quartiers
dans lesquels abstention aurait plutôt
prononcé et bien je médicaux si ce
scrutin à un moment à est victime comme
aux dires de du contexte de
l'environnement national je crois que
mais il faut toute la semaine il faut
que j'aille répétant qu'il s'agit bien
d'un scrutin local d'un scrutin
municipal pour la vie quotidienne des
uns des autres et donc je veux
m'adresser à l'ensemble des auxerrois je
veux continuer pour ce second tour de
badr et c'est à l'ensemble des soins et
rassembler le plus largement possible la
clé ce sera la remobilisation de votre
électorat
ce sera la remobilisation de l'électorat
bien évidemment est plus que jamais
envie de dire dès ce soir